we are back we're back
do that same old place
welcome back okay ready are you done
okay
[Music]
hi everybody welcome back
um a lot has happened since you've seen
us last like that that's done
[Music]
cabin Castle is finished and covid
messed everything up so we weren't able
to produce as many episodes showing the
process but today we're going to catch
all up on what you missed and give you
the tour
[Music]
in the last episode we had some stuff
done we had the bones of the house with
the roof uh framed and we had the
sheathing up but there has been a lot
since then since then we hunted for
shingles that we salvaged from a burn
down cedar shingle Factory shingled the
whole thing
we put the roof sheathing the metal roof
we put Moss up first piece
he grew all the grass we did Maple
floors on the inside Cedar on the walls
in the ceiling inside it took a lot to
get us here
there were some hard times building this
place yeah keeping the wood dry that was
hard
and making sure that it was not going to
change there was a stable moisture level
inside
where we live is gorgeous it's green and
it's Lush and that's like why we picked
pictures and why we wanted to build
cabin land here but the reality is
building in that is very very tough it
was wet and the rain was relentless
incessant and it's what makes this place
so beautiful but it is also poses a lot
of challenges for building
but that being said once we got the roof
on got it all dried in as they say then
the glory work came in but the glory
work was also challenging yeah my knees
are killing me our living roof looks
just like amazing now
[Music]
and that is because Jacob has been a
little obsessive over it to get the
grass to actually grow like Sarah was
saying was actually really challenging
and we started by doing just a typical
chicken wire and Moss that I like to do
we did most of this roof but not this
section first of all let's just take a
minute to look at that beautiful blanket
to get the grass to grow on the roof
even though there was a lot of direct
sunlight in the summer months when there
was no rain coming down that was a
challenge okay but enough talking about
it let's take you inside so you can see
it for yourself
[Music]
hello come on in
welcome to the castle cabin
[Music]
and this is our living room this is what
you first enter when you walk into the
castle cabin yes the idea is that when
you come in your eyes are drawn down
these two hallways right here and to do
that we kind of had the lay the flooring
down in a particular way where it splits
in your line of sight kind of goes down
both hallways and then comes up and is
drawn up into this cathedral-like
ceiling when you walk in you look down
the hallways you look up and then you
start to notice like my new obsession
with plants so they're everywhere
they're growing up the walls this one
right here one of our absolute favorites
I can't wait till this one
like the window and starts climbing
across the rafters and to other windows
and I just want this to be just like a
crazy looking jungle in here one day and
then this is the beginning of the
custom-made Furniture throughout the
house which is our little entertainment
center so you start seeing this pattern
at the front door and then it continues
here and starts going all throughout the
house let's see if we can find all the
places it's like a worse
and of course more and more plants this
beauty is one of my favorites this big
old aloe plant I love it but I stab
myself in this rhinoceros of a horny
I have heard I watch a lot of America's
Next Top Model and then this is another
salvage door we got It's actually an old
schoolhouse store
the pattern the pattern is another place
where we find the pattern get your head
out of the way we're trying to show off
the pattern hey homie we got two dogs
and a matter less than a year
it's a weird idea to get two dogs when
we still didn't even officially have a
house yet to live in but we did it
oh God babe first we got Homer
he is our first born
[Music]
we got him from a rescue from California
and he is like the sweetest thing he
makes our hearts melt
and Peter he's a lucky dog he got him
second and yeah he came from Taiwan and
we got him from an adoption agency that
works with dogs that are uh kind of
feral dogs out there we kind of got
Peter for Homer Homer and him played so
well together we're like best friends
and it was amazing
people always ask us when we're gonna
have kids and the answer is we already
have kids these are our babies yes
so when you when you're in the living
room you can either go down hallway
number one which leads to the kitchen
and bedroom which is the tallest biggest
cabin or you can go down hallway number
two which leads to the medium-sized
cabin
we are now entering the hallway that
leads to The Loft cabin
[Music]
we got a little bit of art here like
this was a photograph the producer um
behind the camera right now he shot last
time he was here it really kind of feels
like you can like step into the
rainforest which I guess that's what
happens when you just walk out the front
door and this is my favorite part of
walking through the house get through
the hallway opens up to the tallest
ceiling we'll take you up into the Loft
in a second but I want to show you into
the into the bathroom real quick
all right
we did all the tile work and the
sheetrocking of all that ourselves
custom-made little vanity by Jacob sorry
I got stuck out there with the dogs how
many times have we seen this pattern
this is the third time we keep counting
this is the third time and we just love
this pattern this may be weird to most
people because like maybe you live in
the city and you want privacy when you
go to the bathroom but we live in the
middle of nowhere no one can see us but
I specifically got like a door with a
big old window so I can sit here take a
pee or whatever look out on our front
desk whatever else you do when you're
sitting on the toilet so this is a
really nice spot and I got this we made
this so I could sit next to her while
she's doing it
that's the bathroom downstairs
and then out back into the medium-sized
cabin I can't wait to take you upstairs
into the Loft but first just a little
quick detour
um again handmade door by Jacob fourth
time with the pattern the fourth time
with the pattern tell them your favorite
part about this my favorite part is the
kitty door down here for Dexter and I
think he's probably laying on a chair in
the kitchen so I'm sure you'll see him
in there yeah he owns the furniture
basically behind this is our
check out the action on that door that's
so nice and smooth but anyway
laundry room
you know just the laundry room
so Up the Ladder into the loft
[Music]
foreign
the ladder up one of the first things
you're going to notice is this gorgeous
railing and that Jacob made thank you so
much and these saplings that we use down
here for the balusters we left the moss
on and actually we learned from the
first railing that we did in the kitchen
that if you leave this moss on it
actually holds on to the color another
really cool thing about these balusters
right here are these smaller branches
that we have kind of wrapped and twisted
around the railing and the key to doing
that is to use the wood while it's still
green because you can kind of Bend and
twist them they're malleable that's like
my favorite thing about it I think and
also this really cool couch you might
also notice upstairs the Fat Cat yeah
Dexter he likes to climb the ladder so
we can get away from the dogs I love
this spot like we're just nice and
nestled up in the ceiling and you can
see the top of the living room cabin
this is actually one of my very favorite
things about this space is that you're
inside the ceiling it's the closest that
you get to the ceiling and so you're
right walking right amongst these collar
ties and this is that collar tie system
that my dad designed when we took him
our idea for the cabins that were shaped
this way doing these ceilings was a lot
of work yeah Ethan and I worked all
through the summer hanging all the wall
material all the ceiling material and we
haven't even mentioned the fact that all
the wall material and the ceiling
material and all the trim are the
seconds from this Cedar Sawmill they're
like The Castaways the pieces that most
people don't want because they have
knots that are too big or imperfections
alright so this this is the Loft now
we're gonna head back downstairs through
the hallways through the living room and
into the kitchen
the hallway admire this beautiful
bookshelf Mr whistling here thank you
foreign
count with how many times this pattern
has showed up so right in with the count
let us know okay
um and then we have all these faces were
made by Jacob's brother he's like a
really good artist
these are all the books that we display
like trophies that we pretend we've read
or anything like that I listened to
Books Okay I love listening to books but
let's go on into the kitchen so here we
are yep in the kitchen
this is where all the action happens
[Applause]
[Music]
the kitchen is probably where we spend
the most time
[Music]
where we play board games it's where we
do our Yahtzee
before we cook our meals
that Center Island that's what has
become our dining room area
so this is where we spend a lot of our
time at the island here yeah on uh this
beautiful old bowling alley that we
found yeah we got all our countertops
our bowling alleys and you can see this
is like the Middle Lane lines and over
here we have the starting lines and this
was all really difficult to work but so
worth it and then it sits on top of
these stainless steel cabinets that this
was all Sarah this idea it might be nice
to break up the wood just a little bit
and bring in some some other material so
we went with stainless steel cabinets
which I love this is my favorite window
of the whole house it's got the most
plants in it I love sitting in the
kitchen and having dinner because we got
a big window to look out on our
beautiful back deck
with all the plants and the lights
and it's like such a mood
[Music]
so that's pretty much pretty much for in
here but wait till you see what's behind
you and above you
and now we're on the other side of the
room and we're looking at our stair
railing going up into the bedroom this
was Jacob's first experimentation with
using the saplings for the balusters and
it leads to one of the coolest most
happening places in the whole house
so when you go upstairs you reach the
bedroom and our second bathroom
[Music]
tallest building of all three of them
so now we are in the bedroom yes
yes my favorite place yeah because I get
to sleep I get my 10 hours of sleep a
night here but you get to lay in bed
here and look up to the ceiling in the
big triangular Windows look out at the
big trees and the headboard oh yeah I I
was gonna buy a headboard to try and you
know
snake Jacob relax it a little bit but he
insisted on building one which I'm
actually really glad he did because it
turned out gorgeous and it's a nod to
our Diamond cabin we've been living in
here for a little while and I was
missing the diamond cabin and I thought
that this would be kind of cute to do
got the pattern once again count it and
uh yeah we thought we would have would
have space to
closet a custom closet in here but turns
out not yes and that's okay just got
like a couple of tall dressers to put
like the Necessities like underwear
socks and pajamas originally I was
hoping to be able to take our clothes
out of what was called the Wardrobe
cabin but it's still just the Wardrobe
cabin we keep all of our clothes out in
the wardrobe cabin and we have just a
couple small dressers in there for like
our undies and socks and pajamas and
then we want to put the real clothes on
we walk outside and walk down the
boardwalk that leads us to the Wardrobe
cabin and we get dressed in there and
that's fine it's more space anyway so I
can pretty much keep all my clothes in
the house that's true but we have a job
what is it a junk drawer in the kitchen
I don't have anything in that
I have nothing got all sorts of things
we got glass pipes we got incense we've
got a petty egg yeah every single thing
oh sorry this petty egg is
that's
okay I have a whole wardrobe cabin
that's a mess like fine you can never
draw yes use a junk cabin
I get a junk drawer Sarah gets a jump
cap
into the upstairs bathroom come come on
this is the same Douglas first slab uh
with the Live Edge we got from the local
Sawmill and this is I think that my
favorite tile work in the whole house
one of my favorite Parts about doing
this house was all of the tile work that
was really where Sarah and I like worked
the closest together it's a small
actually a really small
[Music]
60 square foot house square footage Wise
It's a pretty small house yes height
wise yeah
cubic footage wise I think it's like 3
000 when it's cubic feet so there's a
lot of space but not a lot of footprint
three times as tall as it is yeah yeah
yeah yeah it is actually
foreign
oh my gosh that is it ah that is not
positive energy dude it was a lot that
was a lot that was a lot we built the
whole freaking house I can't believe it
it's been almost two whole years
actually I think it's been two years
since we started building it and coven
messed everything up with the production
but this was the biggest thing that
we've ever undertaken
[Music]
thank you and now it's time to what what
are we gonna do next oh my God you want
to chill
right she wants to chill for a little
bit don't get me wrong it was really
special spending time together building
the house and the cabins and the other
structures it was a bonding experience
yes but it's been so nice having this
house finally done because I have needed
some down time to stop working and just
kind of be able to reconnect I think
I've I've realized that we've missed
we've we've lacked the like the more
intimately of connection
we're always kind of like working and
it's sweet but you know slowing down
across from each other having coffee
it's been nice to go to the beach and
play with the pups and it's been nice to
be able to just play games that's why we
needed this house so we could just relax
for a little bit I'm excited to get back
to work don't get me wrong but I need
some down time yeah three days from now
she's gonna be like let's go I guarantee
it all right that's it that's the end of
season two about the castle cabin thank
you so much to everyone who helped us
and supported us along the way we hope
you come back for season three we have
so many projects and so many things on
the horizon yeah
come on let's see the elevator oh okay
ready yeah
you gotta come down
push the button
[Music]
s
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]